this woman has more in the burnt to Fury
than you ever have in Allah subhana wa
tala isn't that
shameful just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your that you read it wherever
you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends this is how we know Islam is the
truth the comes out one way or another
the video we're about to watch is
literally sh in active like in action
literally if you listen to this woman
very carefully this is called the burnt
toast Theory and look what they derive
out of the burn toast Theory which is
actually attributes of subhana and it
ties back to Allah and the lack of
listen to it for yourself in girl listen
I need to tell you about burnt toast
Theory because my life has gotten
exponentially better once I started
leaning into this and burnt toast theory
is the idea that in the morning you burn
your toast so you have to make a second
piece of toast and as a result you miss
a terrible car accident it's the thought
that every inconvenience that happens to
you is really con inspiring in your
favor for your good to almost give you a
second chance at life so in your dating
life this looks like somebody ghosts you
great they've spared you from their
inability to communicate someone tells
you they're just not feeling it awesome
frees you up to find someone who is
someone cheats on you fantastic they
showed you who they truly were it was
bound to come out eventually and trust
me when I say that whatever stage it
happens at is better than further down
the road everything is burnt toast so
guys what you saw there in a nutshell is
B basically what she's saying is the
following so the burn toast theory in a
nutshell is if you wake up and from what
she said is basically you intentionally
burnt your toast I think that is not
right but arguments say you woke up you
put toast you're late to work whatever
it may be and your toast got burnt so
what they would do is obviously you have
to Reed do do another toast and that's
going to do what cause you to delay now
that delay is going to do what they are
saying that don't be upset or mad about
the toast being burned because it could
be that that is preventing you from
maybe an accident or something bad
happening brothers and S what does this
remind you of literally the of Allah
literally in Allah it's unbelievable in
a nutshell they are using the calling it
The Burnt Toast Theory and they are
making self satisfying theel by saying
my toast got burnt which means that
something bad may have happened
therefore I have in the toast burning
that it saved me so the universe played
a role this isul in Allah We Believe
Allah subhana wa tala is the all knowing
he's the most wise and one of the six
pillars of IM is what we believe in the
predestiny the good and the bad meaning
for example if I really want to go and
do something and for some odd reason
there are obstacles happening or
something happens we are like okay this
might be a sign that Allah subhana wa
ta'ala the God Almighty the true God is
protecting me not a toast not a toast
for that matter it's the one that
created the toast it's the one that
created the universe it's the one that
created the heavens and the Earth so as
you can see this is sh in action and is
what and I'm not blaming the woman CU
obviously they don't know better this is
why we need Islam this is why is the
biggest
this is why sh is so prevalent brothers
and sisters because our trust is in who
Allah look at the level the non-muslims
are going to to make theel content with
life by believing in the burnt to Theory
and you my brother and sister have Islam
you my brother and sister have Allah you
have his attributes the true Lord that
should be worshiped and guess what you
don't even have this taul this woman has
more taul in the burnt to Fury than you
ever have in Allah subhana wa tala isn't
that shameful and the same goes to me
the same goes goes to me brothers and
sisters have trust in Allah how many of
us want to do something so bad we think
it's good Allah says in the Quran you
might love something which is bad for
you and you might hate something which
is good for you and this is what Islam
saves you from the fact that I came to
Islam the contentment I have in my heart
knowing that Allah has written
everything as long as I do my Salah and
do what's on me stay away from major
sins do my that when I walk out and
something bad happens to me it was
written and it was the best thing that
happened to me because Allah is the all
knowing so dish the burnt Theory my dear
sisters non-muslim sisters and brothers
come to Islam and have that connection
with your lord and have the Peace of
heart knowing everything is written even
that toast that is burned it is written
by Allah not by itself till next
time